m
c'est en noir et blanc que les élèves du
collège bourvellec entreprises en alors
rendez vous avec les clips ce jeudi 1er
septembre
depuis plusieurs mois déjà élèves et
enseignants préparer cet événement
exceptionnel
alors monsieur le recteur nous a demandé
de faire de cette journée ordinaire un
événement extraordinaire
donc ce qu'elle nous a motivés bien sûr
pour mettre en place
le projet eclipse et dans le collège de
bourbon le problème crucial bien sûr
d'un tel événement c'est la sécurité
puisqu'il y a un certain nombre de
risques qui
qu'ils sont bien réelles dans un canot
men tel que celui là tels qu'une éclipse
l'ensemble donc des professeurs se sont
investis et ont sensibilisé les élèves à
ces risques majeurs maintenant des mois
de préparation d'être une interrogation
des superstitions surgissent à quelques
minutes du phénomène on est plusieurs
professeurs la avoir pris ce projet en
main parce que déjà je pense que nous ça
nous ça nous parle aussi
moi personnellement j'ai encore jamais
assisté à une éclipse et une fois une
éclipse partielle
donc je trouve que c'est assez
extraordinaire
et au fur et à mesure de la préparation
de cet événement on s'est pris au jeu et
on a appris plein de choses et puis on
fait monter la pression et moi je me
pose pas de questions je ne sais pas
jusqu'à quel point il va faire froid
jusqu'à quel point il va faire sombre
mes élèves se demandait ce que les
chauves souris vont revenir
est-ce que les oiseaux qui d'ordinaire
viennent se poser en fin de journée sur
les arbres de la cour est ce qu'ils vont
venir à 14h08 à tout un tas de questions
comme ça qui sont intéressants depuis
plusieurs jours une vingtaine d'élèves
de la brigade éclipse ont répondu aux
questions de leurs camarades et leur ont
fait part de quelques recommandations à
une éclipse et quand la lune passe entre
le soleil et la terre par rapport à la
distance de la lune par avoir la tâche a
fait une éclipse annulaire au total sont
que ça se ferait sans quoi deux fois
dans une vie déjà la prochaine écrit
dans longtemps ma forme et ses dunes est
déjà pourquoi ce qu'il ya le soleil le
soleil qui envoient des rayons
ultraviolets
le keeper ima abus et la vue ou bien
nous rendre aveugle l'établissement
s'est beaucoup cariste vous rendre ce
moment exceptionnel d'ivoire actions ont
été mises en place telles que des
ateliers d'observation la mise en place
d'un solar scop des quizz ou encore des
flash mobs l'occasion de partager un
moment inoubliable dans une ambiance de
feu
m